hey guys guess what what a secret no
these guys know you guys we have podcast
for you guys now so go over to the
description click on those links and now
you can carry us with you everywhere you
go
yeah and don't forget to read it because
we need those stars oh yeah let us know
communicate with us you like it do you
hate it give us all five stars yeah if
you think it sucks keep it to yourself
and if it's awesome five stars even if
it's like just give us five stars cuz
you know no give us five stars and then
say it sucks just like this video like
the video and tell us it sucks perfect
the thumbs down doesn't exist in [ __ ]
jogger news Oh joggers are kind of
[ __ ] I agree
I suppose the bike lane people keep
taking up the road and [ __ ] like they
[ __ ] run the streets let's run them
over
yeah funny
she's dying from this one good that's a
good possible L friends shut up
it's a game he did another video
onlookers are shocked as a jogger
dismantles a homeless man's encampment
and throws some of it into a nearby lake
I like this guy
Dennis was [ __ ] up that's my homie
he's that I was about to say yeah why
did he do that what did he do he [ __ ]
up a homeless man jacobian magic grab me
like that and a cardboard box and thrown
into a lake Wow and in the naked
homeless guys I why is he naked
he's inside his home on his own so he
assumes that if I crawled into my
cardboard box I'd be naked if I get in
his car he's naked everywhere he's all I
about to hit some crack lips and the
[ __ ] blocks to ice up he's like what
the [ __ ] but he's digging his way yeah
you know but [ __ ] it's the only way to
know he sees this house my way music
good
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what do it and it starts walking in the
water alright so this takes place in
Oakland
do you guys remember when we talked to
barbecue baby Vicki yeah the lady with
the phone she was like oh yeah the
racist cut oh yeah yeah yeah that Dame
Lake Lake Mary oh that's a lady know
this name Lee had that like has a lot of
[ __ ] issues going on around it huh
wait which lady real quick give me a
barbecue Becky uh she was a lady with
the glasses were her freakin frown down
at my cellphone she doesn't mean so what
she did it she approached these black
guys that were having a barbecue at
Mirror Lake and she was saying like you
can't have Tarcoles you can't charcoal
in this area this is not a barbecue area
then the guys are like yeah we checked
the map we can barbecue here oh well not
charcoal you can't have charcoal here
and she was just [ __ ] there for
[ __ ] ever and she wouldn't leave them
alone until finally this other white
lady intervened she was like trying to
even the the barbecue Becky started
treating the white lady like all calm
and nice or whatever she was in being as
aggressive like with the black guy so it
was clearly a race issue then the white
lady ends up showing her a card or
something
barbecue Peggy takes the card and then
the lady starts stalking her and like
following her she's like give me back my
property yeah and then the barbecue
Becky calls the cops and the robber see
Becky get in trouble but the funny thing
is she was all tough until the cops came
and then she put on this act where she
finally started crying like like playing
victim in front of the cops it was like
come on you're you've been recorded this
whole time the entire time you know
black people are booing me yes I see
but her fake cries yeah it was like that
anyway oh yeah that same area okay same
lady not the Lena River but there was uh
there was a guy that was in the barbecue
situation that was involved somehow in
this situation too maybe he lives are on
there kicks at their old
yeah so I'm gonna show you guys video
[Music]
whoa why is he littering why did he make
it worse it's touching his mouth I think
they just did all that [ __ ] also put in
the link that's a great idea
yeah oh you was trying to clean it up
it's already clean yeah but he's
throwing it in the lake
let's kill some fish with this I'm home
well okay I'm like I'm still like I
needed much to be washed anyway that's
cool it's cool I needed some new
blankets anyway yeah okay so the jogger
was like look at this filth and he just
grabbed everything and he was trying to
clean it clean it up but he was just
throwing it in the [ __ ] yeah which knows
his pointers yeah it just makes it worse
well he claims that when he went into
the lake he's like oh that was an
accident
didn't [ __ ] go in the lake pull it
out cuz you threw it there cuz that's
basically literally you're [ __ ] up
those how do you keep throwing into the
link if it's an ask enough accident yeah
he's like exed then exit there how do
you keep dump I will say this that
homeless man has more clothes than me
which is amazing he has a lot of clothes
white gets Halle cold up there right oh
he doesn't get that cold oh that's true
I don't know I think it's like bear
you're like really polite it's not like
winter like snow cold yeah yeah yeah
wise it's almost man such a [ __ ] right
nobody said a little [ __ ] no I just
kind of surprised like how much clothes
he has though cuz you see people out
here in LA they don't have like piles of
[ __ ] clothes like that that's crazy
that's [ __ ] up cuz he has not a lot of
clothes he has absolutely nothing and
he's throwing away his nothing I know
well yo he has like three sweaters and
he's like [ __ ] it
yeah it's like damn dude he went out of
his way like the running path was
somewhere far and he walks all the way
across what keep [ __ ] running I mean
I get it though because homeless people
end up [ __ ] up some areas and parks
right but it's not the way to go about
it it's not because they they already
don't have anything so the people in
that neighborhood were saying that this
guy like yes he has an encampment but he
always made sure to keep it out of
people's ways I was just thinking that
tucked in that little corner there but
so now the Internet is dubbing that
jogger hashtag jogger Joe BBQ Becky and
John Joe again so there were a lot of
people just been very next day a lot of
people went back and gave him blankets
and clothes and I'm just trying to know
so what was the homeless guy doing
during this whole time was he like hey
yeah he's not even in the video then he
wasn't around so he was out fishing or
something trying to catch lunch didn't
mean like he was just he comes back to
us I was like what the [ __ ] happened
yeah really
dude there's this one homeless guy I
always see them so you know where I take
my dogs out to go pee and poop like
routine the same people are always there
and this guy could you take it to their
dwelling I mean you make your dogs pnp
bully Joe it's a park it's a park but
there's these benches and a lot of like
homeless guys like they sleep there they
hang out there but there's this one guy
who always has new [ __ ] new clothes new
stuff and he has suitcases like three or
four of them and he has just bags of
[ __ ] and he's always there having like
long conversations with himself
sometimes he's arguing with the spirits
one time he was sitting cross-legged
like this and he was like going like
this
just [ __ ] them but and I see him and
then something like does he see me so I
say hi to him and then he goes like this
and he just points at me he waves so
every time we say what's up he was just
really weird where I'm just like trying
to remember his items and he'll always
have different suitcases different bags
and he's he's just got it pisses you off
right that pisses you off doesn't it
that makes you mad doesn't it it doesn't
make me mad it just makes me wander
where the [ __ ] is he storing all this
[ __ ] because it's like five six bags of
[ __ ] Joe
I also know your memory though and
you'll be like that white car I swear I
saw a white car like wait that car was
gold whose memories better mine or yours
I don't know we're pretty but I
guarantee you though he does have [ __ ]
ton of bags and [ __ ] tons of suitcases
and stuff so I'm like just what the [ __ ]
does he move what do you mean like does
he like move around during the day and
then he comes back yeah yeah he moves
from bench to bench to corner and then
he'll one time he'll just pick
everything up and then he'll leave and
you'll leave half of his [ __ ] there
little tokyo has like the same like
homeless culprits there there's the guy
that screams and curses everybody out oh
the one that's always swinging and
trying to find out you know I remember
that guy's because there was a day where
I told myself that hey you know what you
should talk to homeless people just
because if you don't have money sure at
least say like you don't have any money
right well lo and behold I render this
guy he goes hey man you got some money
on the I would go
[ __ ] you fat boy yeah he's pretty crowd
like that would happen to me like out
the day I decided to be a I was like why
do you I say fat boy bro like why
couldn't just been [ __ ] you like
everybody else man no you called me fat
boy and I was like you know what dude
like that was so unnecessary that's yeah
there are some crazy guys oh there's the
guy with the tattoo number on his head
yeah he asked me like three times a day
one day
and he forgot that I even asked me like
three minutes ago
there's also I just got out of jail and
he puts just like I was like nah man I
just you just asked me I asked you all
right I'm up
it's a does that yeah if you have the
same spiel you love hello sir I just got
out of jail real quick and if you see
this tattoo on my head this is a reason
why nobody will give me a job you have
any money you could spare
every time he just got out he just got
out he's just got out like months ago
yeah
years ago at this point and then there's
a white lady that says she has AIDS
oh geez she's not around I've never seen
she's there I mean it's can I have a hug
her opening is hella hard for it it's
the same she she goes excuse me sir I
have hates love like college is run it
was like that's her opening and then she
asked for money right after
[Music]
[Music]